Небезпека для людей, мільярдні втрати через недоотримання податків,
а на додачу - ще й витрати на демонтаж автозаправних станцій, що працюють по-чорному.
Ось наслідки тіньової торгівлі пальним, яка в Україні,
за різними оцінками, становить від 20 до 30 відсотків усього ринку паливно-мастильних матеріалів.
Вирушаємо подивитися, як працюють АЗС, котрі, як нам повідомили експерти, мають ознаки нелегальності.
DW: А паспорт якості і відповідність є у Вас?
Оператор заправки:  Все є. Треба телефонувати менеджеру, все у нас є.
DW: А покажіть, будь ласка.
-Розумієте, нас тут по три рази перевіряють. Що я Вам дав - документи Вам дав, будь ласка, читайте, що там написано.
Утім, ксерокопії дозвільних документів, які нам показали, та перевірки ще не означають,
що заправка дійсно працює за правилами, кажуть експерти.
Порушена відстань від резервуара до операторної, яка має бути не менше 15 метрів,
порушена відстань - візуально - від резервуара до дороги, яка має бути не менше 10 метрів,
також порушена вимога щодо огородження парканом такого об'єкту.
Він має бути провітрюваний, а відстань від паркану до резервуара має бути не менше 7,5 метрів.
Візуально тут метр, якщо не менше.
Це ті ознаки порушень, які можна бачити одразу - не потрібно навіть рулетку брати.
Обслуговують тут не лише водіїв. Знімальна група DW
задокументувала також заправку побутових газових балонів.
Заправка таких балонів може здійснюватися на заправках, якщо вони розташовані
за межами населених пунктів, виключно. На АЗС та АГЗП, якщо на них облаштовані спеціальні пункти обміну та заправки балонів.
Це кричуще порушення. Який ризик? Газ має здатність
розширюватись при зміні температури, збільшуватися та зменшуватися в об'ємі.
Кілька років тому ми мали випадок, коли такий балон був заправлений на схожій заправці,
його потім взимку занесли в тепле приміщення
і він просто вибухнув і розніс будинок. Це є дуже небезпечно.
За словами експерта, імовірні порушення є і на цій заправці -
вона розташована лише за кілька десятків метрів від попередньої.
Знов-таки, візуально - порушена відстань від газового об'єкта
до бензинових резервуарів, до АЗС. Вона має бути не менше 40 метрів.
Людина, яка сидить в операторній, фактично знаходиться між газовим  і бензиновим резервуаром.
Мені здається, він дуже ризикує.
Вибухи та пожежі на заправках, легальних та не зовсім, не є рідкістю в Україні.
На небезпеку наражаються і водії, і оператори таких станцій.
Питаємо, що вони думають про порушення безпекових норм.
Мені не страшно. Ну, я думаю, тут все за ГОСТом зроблено.
Ви розумієте,  я працівник-"пістолєтчик".
Я на ці питання не можу відповідати.
DW: А Вам не страшно тут працювати?
- Треба ж працювати...
За останні два роки влада декілька разів оголошувала війну "чорним" заправкам.
Нині, за словами віцепрезидента Нафтогазової асоціації України Ярослава Старовойтенка,
з 1,5 тисячі таких об'єктів залишилося декілька десятків.
Деякі з них демонтували, деяким вдалося отримати ліцензії.
Зараз вони зареєстровані, наразі їх повинна перевіряти та контролювати
також Державна архітектурно-будівельна інспекція.
Але, на жаль, останні кілька років вона перебуває у стадії чи то ліквідації,
чи то реорганізації і, можливо, їм не до того. І маємо таку ситуацію.
Багато заправок, навіть легальних на папері, досі працюють недобросовісно.
Економлять на безпеці, продають контрафактне пальне поза касою,
не оформлюють офіційно своїх працівників. Збитки можна оцінити лише приблизно.
Через діяльність тіньового сектору втрати ПДВ і акцизу -
це те, що недоотримує бюджет - близько чотирьох мільярдів на рік.
Це тільки нелегальні - так звані бочки, які стоять під парканами сховані.
Що стосується інших ситуацій, використання різних незаконних схем діяльності
у тому числі "білими" АЗС - дійсно, використовуються певні схеми,
які завдають шкоди бюджету на більші суми, ніж чотири мільярди.
За словами Вадима Мельника, нині над виявленням нелегальних заправок
скоординовано працює десяток служб - від Державної фіскальної служби
до Держслужби з надзвичайних ситуацій.
Утім, визнає посадовець, лише перевірками і демонтажем проблему не подолати.
Ми за кожним не уженемося - у нас не вистачає людей.
Ми живемо у століття диджиталізації, комп'ютеризації і так далі.
Це чіткий правильний облік продукції.
Як на вході в Україну - чи то через трубу, чи то кораблями, які завозять паливо,
так і на виробництвах, і до пістолета, яким заправляється бак.
Чітка система контролю кожного літру.
Це налагоджується, робота у цьому напрямку триває на всіх рівнях.
Але вона не зациклена. От коли буде зациклена, тоді буде результат.
Проте головна причина, чому водії користуються нелегальними та напівлегальними заправками -
висока вартість палива в офіційних конкурентів - залишається.
Антимонопольний комітет вже декілька років розлідує справу
щодо можливої змови низки операторів АЗС. Великі компанії,
своєю чергою, скаржаться, що не можуть знижувати ціну
через нечесну конкуренцію з боку тіньового ринку - таке собі замкнене коло.
Утім, кажуть експерти, заощадити, заправляючи авто неякісним пальним
на сумнівних АЗС, у довгостроковій перспективі не вдасться.
Адже витрати на ремонт можуть бути більшими, ніж економія на пальному.